[Music]
so we'll be talking to martin about his
ideas about his background and of course
about his new book so if i can just
introduce martin for a moment
martin has co-authored more than 500
academic papers on subjects such as the
big bang and dark matter
and he's also a long-standing member of
the house of lords and has previously
been the president of the royal society
this is a position that isaac newton
once held
more recently
in the book that we're here to talk
about today on the future prospects for
humanity
martin has explored the biggest issues
facing the human race today
in his book he talks about the rise of
artificial intelligence
and other issues like climate change and
discusses how we should best combat
these challenges and we will be talking
a little bit more about these issues in
the second part of the interview so i'd
like to start martin by just talking to
you a little bit about yourself and your
career so
did you always know that you wanted to
be an astronomer um
no let me just have no idea what
question she's going to ask me so
italian rehearsal he's also told me that
if he doesn't like a question he'll just
say it's my fault
right yes
no i didn't have any firm childhood
ambition i mean i was interested in
nature and numbers and things um but
then um i proved to be good at maths and
so i was persuaded to
do maths as a student when i went to
university and i decided i didn't like
it very much i wasn't getting a
mathematician so i thought of what to do
using my mathematical skills and i
thought quite seriously about being an
economist
but
um i i then uh through a chain of
accidents if i had the chance to um work
for my phd in a group at cambridge um
which um uh was working on cosmology and
things and i was very lucky because this
was a time
when um there were new discoveries being
made
evidence for the big bang
black holes and things like that
and um i'd give any young person
the advice that if you go into a field
of science pick one where new things are
happening because then the experience of
the old guys is at a discount and you
can make an impact fairly quickly
and i was quite lucky in that sense in
that i was able uh while still a student
and a young researcher to make some
quite significant discoveries
can you tell us a bit about what they
thought
well this was the early days when we
were
finding evidence that our universe
had evolved from some
hot dense beginning
and we were trying to understand how it
changed from that state to its present
state and we were trying to understand
um uh
object called black holes
which are very extreme consequences of
einstein's theory
which
happen
when a star collapses and they exist in
a sense of galaxies and this has been
one of my ongoing interests
so it was really to try to make sense
and i didn't um do any very mathematical
work um i was uh in the same group as
stephen hawking and he was two years
senior to me uh and he diverged towards
doing all my mathematical work and i was
more in touch with observations
but
my work has been very interactive with
observations just trying to make sense
of all the wonderful mysteries which
have been found in in space and of
course the main
advances have come not because of
armchair theorists like me
but
through better and better equipment
telescopes on the ground and in space
and computers to do simulations but we
can't do experiments on stars and
galaxies we can just do
do simulations in in the lab and uh the
people who really deserve the credit are
the um uh people who build these
instruments and work on and uh i was
giving a talk earlier this week to some
engineers um at a conference at the
south bank center and i remind them of a
very nice cartoon that's all engineers
like uh which shows two beavers looking
up at a big hydroelectric dam and one
beaver says to the other i didn't
actually build it which is based on my
idea
as preemptive modesty uh this uh
indicates the balance between what we
armchair theorists do
and what the instrument builders and the
computer scientists do
so what's going to be the equivalent of
the hydroelectric dam do you think
well of course we already have it we
have a huge telescopes and uh
european scientists are building a
telescope in chile
which is um
called the extremely large telescope
they're rather unimaginative
the elt they're rather unimaginative in
the mencouture but it will have a mirror
um 39 meters across and that's i guess
probably a bit bigger than the width of
this this tent um and um that's going to
be uh wonderful new instruments we have
similar things in space which are
smaller and that's going to do a number
of things it's going to be able to probe
further away
and therefore further back in the past
so we understand the early history of
galaxies but also the other exciting
development in our subject has been the
realization that the stars we see in the
sky
are not just twinkling points of light
they are suns
mainly orbited by retinues of planets
just like the
sun is orbited by the earth and the
other familiar planets and these
so-called exoplanets
are
um
very hard to detect they're so faint
that we only know about them indirectly
but these
huge telescopes would be able to
actually image
a possible other earth
around another star and then of course
the next question is is there going to
be life on any of those and they're
going to be like many of these
yes
good question well i think the answer if
you don't know and um uh biology is a
much more complicated subject uh than uh
than physics or astronomy i like to say
that the smallest insect is harder to
understand and then a star or a galaxy
so we don't know yet but we will within
10 or 20 years know if there's some sort
of biosphere on some of these planets um
some evidence for life um intelligent
life of course um is
something which we can't speculate about
even
as definitely as simple life um but um
it's the question i'm most often asked
as an astronomer uh is there any
alien intelligence out there
um and uh i think it's the most
fascinating question um i don't hold my
breath for success but i am involved in
some projects to actually look for
evidence of something artificial out
there or some artificial signal of
course there are some people who
know the answer already i get letters
from people who
say um
they've um
they've met the aliens they've been
abducted by the aliens etc and i um say
two things to these people i'll say
first do you really think that if the
aliens had made the huge effort to uh
traverse interstellar space to come here
would they just make a corn circle meet
one or two well-known cranks and go away
again
seems unlikely
and i tell these people to write to each
other and not to me
[Laughter]
so that that brings us i think quite
nicely onto one of the the main premises
in your book which is a phrase that you
repeat very often in the book um
which is that uh technology is morally
neutral and that no matter how many sort
of bad decisions we've made or bad
things that have happened in the world
as a result of our misuse and abuse of
scientific advancement and technology
you mentioned for example the atomic
bomb that we should still keep going
with with moving forward with artificial
intelligence technology traveling to
other
planet solar systems um now i'm sure we
could all agree that sort of
philosophically that this is probably
true but do you think on some level that
this can be abused that it could be
irresponsible to sort of keep going with
this research
well i mean i think we've got to
distinguish sort of a
basic science understanding nature
understanding atoms um understanding the
environment understanding darwinian
evolution and things like that
which indeed is is is ethically neutral
but of course the way science is applied
uh is anything but ethically neutral and
uh
the way it's supplied is
a decision that should be made just not
just by scientists but of course by the
wider public um and of course uh we see
um many examples of of this where um uh
you mentioned it high bomb is the most
obvious case um was that the right thing
to do etc and we see this now
in biology
we have the possibility to modify uh
people's genome um should we do this to
remove a handicap should we do this for
human enhancement all those are the
questions are you talking about the
crispr cas9 system genetic modification
most people are happy about uh um you
know eliminating huntington's disease or
something like that which you can do by
changing one gene but uh if sort of
human enhancement became possible as it
might one day that's an ethical issue um
and of course uh the uses of
of cyber and ai um are uh of course
they're ambivalent they can be can be
good and bad um and of course
uh medical knowledge um uh has been
certainly benign in uh narrowing the gap
in life expectancy between
um
countries in africa and the rest of the
world but there are some possibilities
where we might be ambivalent so i think
um uh we've got to realize that science
can be applied in a variety of ways and
we have to choose which uh where to go
um uh
there's a panel at midday um on space
travel and i think this is a case when
the um the high point of manned space
flight was 50 years ago neil armstrong's
one small step on the moon um and uh
that was done for political reasons and
quite rightly um there's been no effort
to repeat that because it's a it's
something for which there's no no
purpose um and to give to other examples
um 50 years ago
was the first flight of the concorde
we know what happened to that because
that was a technology which was possible
but there was no no demand for it etc uh
it was also the first commercial flight
to the jumbo jet
and uh the jumbo jet um has continued uh
not very not changed very much
we fly in the same way as we did 50
years ago so
some technologies fizzle out because
there's no demand some
evolve rather slowly
whereas some uh like
ai and the technology in our smartphones
evolve very very fast and they raise
challenges that we've got to cope with
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas